werden in der man kann sagen endlich und
das sind auch viele die das zu mir
gesagt haben im umfeld von präsident
selensky im umfeld von politikern die so
lange druck gemacht haben dass olaf
scholz umgefallen ist und gesagt hat
okay wir liefern jetzt zumindest ein
bisschen denn den ukrainern reicht das
noch nicht sie sagen das kann lange
dauern sie brauchen auch leopard sie
brauchen auch martha warum ist das so
die fläche im don was ist ganz anders
als in kiew dort gibt es eine offene
schlacht dort gibt es keine
möglichkeiten für die ukrainische armee
sich zu verstecken und dann wieder
anzugreifen sondern das ist diese offene
gefährliche schlacht die sie dort führen
müssen aber mich hat heute etwas anderes
aufgeregt nena und zwar die tatsache wie
in deutschland diskutiert wird und wie
auch in europa diskutiert wird denn
immer dann wenn man wenn politiker wenn
experten dafür eintreten dass
deutschland noch mehr panzer liefern
sollen dann wird gesagt na ja wir müssen
ja auch die nato-staaten schützen das
ist aus meiner sicht ein lächerliches
argument denn hier in der ukraine wo ich
gerade stehe hier passiert nichts
anderes als dass die nato geschützt wird
und zwar dadurch dass wladimir putins
truppen zurückgedrängt werden dadurch
dass die ukrainische armee gegen diese
armee kämpft und damit hat sie natürlich
auch weniger möglichkeiten hier nato
staaten anzugreifen es sind tausende
manche gehen davon aus über 20 tausend
russische soldaten tragischerweise muss
man dazu sagen hier in der ukraine
bereits gestorben und alles was die
ukraine hier tut ist am ende die nato zu
verteidigen und ich glaube dass müssen
endlich auch die pazifisten in
deutschland verstehen und aufhören davon
zu reden dass man hier der ukraine nicht
helfen sollen frau keller können sie das
nato argument der waffengegner verstehen
nein das kann ich absolut nicht
verstehen nicht als dass es wirklich so
ist unsere frieden unsere freiheit wird
momentan in der ukraine verteidigt und
ist es wirklich unsäglich wie unser
bundeskanzler die
verteidigungsministerin die spd hier
jetzt wochenlang laviert hat dass wir
überhaupt mal zu potte kommen auch
waffen zu liefern
das war bei den sanktionen nicht anders
stichwort trifft aber eben auch dann
weiter gehen bei der frage ob er waffen
liefern und jetzt eben auch schwere
waffen und wir brauchen bei allem zu
lange es kann nicht sein dass wir
innerhalb der nato innerhalb der eu
immer die letzten sind die am ende dann
weiß auch wahrscheinlich wegen
internationalem druck und dem streit
jetzt auch beim thema schwere waffen
lieferung innerhalb der koalition gar
nicht mehr anders geht die spd dann
irgendwann mal ein lenkt sondern wir
müssen da wirklich auch mal wieder vor
die welle kommen und das erwarte ich
auch von einem bundeskanzler
er hat vor einigen wochen eine große
ansprache im deutschen bundestag
gehalten aber an taten muss man sagen
ist im leider echt wenig gefolgt ist
jetzt ich will mal ein bisschen wasser
in den wein gießen ich kann mich der
euphorie wegen der jetzt beschlossenen
lieferung von gebhard panzer nicht
anschließen es ist ja altes gerät das
die bundeswehr gar nicht mehr hat und
das wird viele wochen dauern bis die
panzer so hergerichtet sind dass sie
einsatzfähig werden dann müssen auch
leute daran geübt und trainiert werden
das dauert endlos lang das ist also ein
gerät das gar nicht aktuell gebraucht
werden kann im kampf um die ost ukraine
und ich bin langsam so weit dass ich den
satz den olaf scholz mehrfach gesagt hat
er sich so merkwürdig anhört selbst wenn
ich nichts tue ist das führung dass man
diesen satz ernst nehmen muss ich habe
nämlich den eindruck dass es in
westlichen hauptstädten in berlin zumal
im kanzleramt ein konzept geben könnte
das darauf hinausläuft
sich den kopf zu zerbrechen wie eine
politische lösung aussehen könnte am
ende die keine lösung auf dem
schlachtfeld ist und diese lösung könnte
so aussehen dass die ost ukraine in
russland fällt mit der süd ukraine bis
hin zur krim dass das das ergebnis ist
was man jetzt schon im kopf mit sich
trägt und dass man also auch bewusst
zögerlich ist bei der lieferung von
material weil die verhandlungen
überhaupt erst in gang kommen wir reden
heute abend bei frau song nochmal über
die these die verhandlungen zwischen
russland ukraine kommen überhaupt das
ernsthaft in gang wenn die russen ein
gewisses ziel erreicht
ronzheimer dargestellt hat da kann ich
natürlich auch na ja ich wollte dafür
den paul mahl zu rufen seit voriger
versailles deutschen panzer angeht das
ist keine große leistung die zu zu sagen
dann fragen wir doch jetzt erstmal paul
bevor ich zu ihnen komme paul ist es
denn keine große leistung diese panzer
zu zu sagen
ja uli hat natürlich völlig recht also
das ist das was ich ja auch gerade
berichtet habe daß man leopard dass man
mader will aber in ihrer verzweiflung
sind die ukraine bei dem was sie in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten aus
deutschland gehört haben der erst einmal
freudig gestimmt dass rolf mützenich
selbst der spielt mittlerweile in der
ukrainischen innenpolitik eine rolle der
spd-fraktionschef überstimmt wurde das
oder scholz doch schon eine art
kehrtwende hingelegt hat also das wird
hier erst einmal ganz grundsätzlich
positiv bewertet aber wenn wir über die
feinheiten sprechen unser kollege julian
röcke hat dazu ja einige dinge enthüllt
dass nicht genügend munition da ist dass
es ewig dauern wir dass diese panzer
kommen also das ist das große problem
und ich glaube um diesem argument der
nato was ich dort genannt habe das ist
eine von vielen ausreden gewesen also
wenn ich mit deutschen politikern
insbesondere von der spd gesprochen habe
in den vergangenen monaten habe ich
eigentlich jede woche eine neue ausrede
gehört warum bestimmte dinge jetzt doch
auf gar keinen fall möglich sind und der
nächsten woche gab es dann eine weitere
ausrede eine sache die muss man dennoch
diskutieren es gibt eine aktuelle
umfrage bei rtl n tv wo über 60% ich
knapp 65 prozent der deutschen den kurs
von olaf scholz unterstützen
zurückhaltend zu sein da scheint ist
dann doch einen unterschied ich nenne es
mal in der veröffentlichten und in der
öffentlichen meinung zu geben bin
gespannt wie du das ist die
gemessene meinung in deutschland hat
mich fast meine meinung angeht überhaupt
nie interessiert oder nur am rande
interessiert ist ja genau das was ich
für richtig halte und du tust es ja auch
paul absolut aber das ist ja interessant
yazdi was die was die deutschen angeht
und ihre ängstlichkeit
da haben wir ja schon während der
kubakrise entsprechende erfahrungen
gemacht da habe ich die deutschen von
einer völlig neuen seite kennen gelernt
und da scheint sich fortzusetzen
ich halte diese entscheidung jetzt diese
merkwürdigen panzer zu liefern für ein
taktisches manöver das auch dazu dient
diese jetzt regierende koalition zu
retten denn die ist näher am zerbrechen
als man vielleicht öffentlich wahrnimmt
diese diese frage wie die ukraine
unterstützt wird kann die frage sein an
der sich entscheidet ob die ampel
koalition in zukunft hat oder nicht jede
politische lager heißt es sucht sich die
koalition die ihr angemessen ist und
diese lage jetzt hat nicht ein
entsprechender koalition in berlin
und scholz muss sehr aufpassen dass ihm
die grünen nicht ausbrechen und dann
auch die fdp folgt also ich sehe eher
innenpolitische motive als
außenpolitische auf jeden fall keine
ernsthaften versuch der ukraine zu
helfen aber wo ist dann können sie den
etwas positives an dem kurs von
einem gesamt kurs da hatte ich diesmal
zurück aber zumindest an dem jetzigen
schritt das ist ein schritt in die
richtige richtung aus meiner sicht es
ist mehr als wir noch vor ein paar tagen
gesehen haben es war wirklich dieses
lange zögern ich finde ist tatsächlich
ein bisschen peinlich dass deutschland
immer von globaler verantwortung spricht
und dann in solchen situationen sich
relativ weit hinten einreiht was die
unterstützung angeht von wirklich von
der ukraine in diesem fall
ich bin überrascht dass sie in der
kroner krise die ängstlichkeit der
deutschen kennen gelernt habe
durchaus schon vorher zu tage war es ist
ja auch was also um an diesem zögern
auch was gutes zu finden es gibt ja
dieses case szenario dass es zu einer
eskalation kommt das ist zu einem
tatsächlich bündnisfall kommen könnte
das liegt nicht in der hand der nato es
liegt in der hand von wladimir putin
wenn er sagt dass er sich jetzt auch von
der nato angegriffen fühlt dann haben
wir ein problem das wirklich noch viel
viel größer ist das heißt also die sich
vielleicht jetzt nicht so diese german
angst schüren ich will nur sagen
natürlich gibt es die überlegung
und natürlich gibt es auch eine gefahr
der eskalation die kann man nicht völlig
vom tisch schieben man muss sie nur in
andere gleichermaßen wahrscheinliche
szenarien ein rein und da ist nicht das
einzige szenario was das wahrscheinlich
ist aber es gibt es gibt
unterschiedliche und die meisten
szenarien ist es einfach wichtig dass
andere länder die ukraine mit waffen und
eben mit schweren waffen beliefern damit
die in den sie sollen auf lügen einmal
und dann rufe ich jetzt sage ich glaube
der war gerade was mit der scheidung
herum sommer kein turnier jetzt haben
wir gehört wie er hier versuchen die
scheite wieder aufzubauen deswegen
bedanke ich mich jetzt hier schon mal
einmal bei paul schallte es gerade nicht
mehr möglich aber seine these
debattieren wird auch zu ende gehen
also mit einfach die ukrainische armee
nicht vorzeitig aufgegeben wird
wir haben ja wirklich einen einen
kriegsverlauf der sehr schwer
einzuschätzen ist allein aufgrund der
tatsache dass jemand hier den
angriffskrieg begonnen hat von dem ich
glaube keiner so richtig sagen kann was
er in einer woche tun wird was er in
vier und zwei stunden und einem oder
ganz kurz regierung bereit wann ist
ihnen denn ich fand das so nett mit der
german angst wann es ihnen denn die
german angst und das thema abzurunden
das erste mal begegnet hier ist nicht
nur weil die ukraine krieg sondern
natürlich auch schon vorher diese
generelle zögerliche zurückhaltende art
auch natürlich wenn man mal einen in
afghanistan krieg noch mal zurück den
irakkrieg es ist generell vielleicht bei
den deutschen weit verbreitet hier eher
zögerlich zu sein aber ich will doch
dazu sagen putin wird erst dann den
krieg beenden oder einen
waffenstillstand machen wenn geschlossen
der restliche teil der welt ihm
gegenüber tritt und mit allem was zur
verfügung steht sei es politisch oder
eben mit militärischen mitteln
entgegentritt und er in seiner
kalkulation sagt das kann ich nicht mehr
für mich wenden und dann wird er
aufhören vorher kein stück wird immer
mehr ziele sich ausdenken bevor gestoppt
wird